Let me show you this other slide. This is from another very well at book.
Which I have here on my on my desk. The book
is called.
fundamentals of machine learning and predictive data analytics
this is from
MIT press again. I'll include the book.
in the references file
but this is hopefully going to help you understand the concept intuitively
suppose we have
a picture with a triangle in it
this one
and we want to know what it is that we're looking at.
each
perceptron and now we only have one hidden layer. So this is a very
simplified example.
Each perceptron is hidden layer.
Is going to look at one feature of this picture.
So for example, if you see here we have.
One segment of the triangle here. We
have another segment of the triangle here. We have another yet another
segment of the triangle.
Second here the layer.
Is going to combine the information from the previous end layer.
And I will say oh we are forming an angle.
So that's one angle form. That's one.
I don't want to use the word feature, but that is one.
Part of the picture that this machine learning has discovered.
And the same thing for the second perceptron of the Hidden layer.
And you can see once we pass these two.
And by the way, they're vectors, right? These are
vectors of the features. We pass this
to the Apple layer. Then the perceptron will put these two
pieces of puzzles together and I will say okay we're looking at a
triangle. So this is supposed to be intuitive approach.